with almost 500 sessions in next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
implementing FinTech security in the
cloud then stay tuned because here's the
rewind moving your company's workloads
to the public cloud can be scary it
feels like a huge security risk and
often you're dealing with your most
closely guarded intellectual property to
succeed in migrating you need to figure
out how to protect your IP from theft or
attack while also making sure your
stakeholders can get access to the data
they need let's see how to sigmah did it
start to finish based in New York to
Sigma is a texture of an investment
company that's moving to the cloud while
also juggling the needs of internal
modelers developers and security teams
alongside external communities of users
and developers we'll walk through how
they created a secure Google cloud
platform architecture opening up new
opportunities for scale that they could
not achieve with on-premise solutions
they begin like any of us with a brand
new GCP account and a super admin
identity or - of course they have
existing on-premise resources including
their authoritative identity provider in
this case Active Directory then they
create a few compute and storage
resources securing those cloud assets
requires good policies in this case
we'll use Identity and Access Management
policies to restrict who can access
storage buckets compute instances and
both front and back-end applications
even before we create any substantive
content as we continue to build and
secure this architecture we repeatedly
ask ourselves
what have we secured and what are the
existing concerns what's still
vulnerable or what could be abused
where do we have opportunities to
improve our ability to audit and how can
we make things easier for our
stakeholders let's take your super admin
accounts these are very very powerful
and need strong protections because they
could do almost anything with your data
which is why leveraging security keys is
essential for these high-value accounts
or maybe all accounts
security keys guard against phishing
more effectively than alternate second
factors that's because you can't fool a
security key with a fake domain or a
fake certificate we've seen tremendous
benefits at Google from using them and
many clients utilize this open standard
to safeguard their accounts to even
accounts are very secure people can lead
your company's data accidentally you can
prevent this with org-wide policies in
this case preventing any resource for me
accessed by anybody outside the domain
going even further we've created a
virtual private cloud construct inside
our GCP architecture so that no app data
inside the VPC can be accessed from
anything outside this creates a strong
Network boundary and prevents data from
going to another GCP project which could
leak it keeping your data safe also
requires preventing employees from
exfiltrating data to prevent a malicious
insider from moving data from one GCP
resource to another you can restrict all
resources inside your VPC to be
accessible only to other resources
inside the same VPC on top of this you
can use identity where proxy to allow
specific people to access the VPC
resources from anywhere on the Internet
especially useful for contractors or
remote workers who need to connect to
these systems from outside your office
environment IP restricts access based on
identity so you choose who gets access
rather than getting access based on
where someone sits now that you've got a
great security set up you're done right
if things do go wrong and they probably
will some time you'll need to find out
what happened and when we'll use
stackdriver to manage logs tracking what
happened every step of the way so you
can investigate after an incident to get
a view of your overall security status
we'll use cloud security command center
to aggregate your security metrics into
a single dashboard and we use for SETI
to increase your automation around
security policy application and
monitoring so new projects will adhere
to the same security standards securing
your GCP resources relies on layering
policies and good architecture practices
and is possible even if you're starting
from scratch as you've seen here thanks
for watching you can see the full talk
link in the description below so
scribe to the cloud YouTube channel for
more next rewind videos
you
[Music]